[Music]
great
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for
educators they're already talking about
this is the nobel for teachers for
surprise for
teaching excellence million dollar prize
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done is to reawaken
the world's appreciation of the
importance of teachers
when each of us thinks about what we can
do in life
chances are we can do it because of a
teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change our
world for the better
being a great teacher requires
resilience ingenuity
and a generous heart all of you who are
the finalists in this year's global
teacher prize
[Music]
congratulations
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers
to transform students lives a good
teacher holds the power to influence
inspire and shape a young person's life
for the better
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience
the real superheroes are teachers
they're the ones that changed
[Music]
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for
educators they're already talking about
this is the nobel for teachers
for surprise for teaching excellence
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done
is to reawaken the world's appreciation
of the importance of teachers when each
of us thinks about what we can do in
life
chances are we can do it because of a
teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change
our world for the better being a great
teacher
requires resilience ingenuity and a
generous heart
all of you who are the finalists in this
year's global teacher prize
congratulations
[Music]
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers
to transform students lives a good
teacher holds the power to influence
inspire and shape a young person's life
for the better
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes
are teachers they're the ones that
[Music]
changed
wherever you're watching this from
around the world i want to welcome you
to the global teacher prize ceremony
2020.
this year in particular we all owe our
teachers a huge debt of gratitude
i know from personal experience how
great teachers
can dramatically change the course of a
young person's life for the better
that's why teaching really is a
profession like no other
because as a teacher you're only
responsible for educating our young
people
but encouraging them too and nothing
could be more
important now i'd like to introduce
you to our very special host this
evening he's a british
national treasure speaking to you for
one of our capitals
most treasured buildings i am so
delighted
to welcome stephen fry who's standing at
the entrance
of the natural history museum in london
well thank you so much to sadiq khan the
mayor of london
now wherever you are on our planet good
morning
good afternoon good evening and thank
you for helping us
celebrate the noblest profession in the
world
teaching it's my distinct privilege and
pleasure
to be helping present the 2020 global
teacher prize
here at the natural history museum in
london
not so much a building more a kind of
feral sweater
see you inside
the global teacher prize goes to
nancy atwell
[Music]
maggie mcdonnell and this is for all the
top 50s out there
teachers teachers
[Music]
tonight is about celebrating all the
teachers and the important role they
play
in shaping the future for our children
[Music]
so are you ready all right peter tabachi
let us always remember when you promote
education
you are empowering the society and
changing the world for the better
well i'm here in the museum's hintsy
hall a place of
real magic and wonder a place where time
seems to stand still for over a hundred
years this
grand hall and its winding corridors
have cast a spell over endless teachers
and students that have walked through
them
since the museum's grand opening in 1881
in fact i remember when i was a boy and
i first came here
i asked one of the sort of custodians of
uniform gentlemen
how old one of the dinosaurs was and he
told
me that it was 150 million
and 21 years old i said to him that's
extraordinarily
precise is that carbon dating that
enables you to pin it down so accurately
he said no when i first came here i was
told it was 150 million years old and
i've been here 21 years
so anyway young people have from every
corner of the world
stared in awe as i did at those
dinosaurs under the woolly mammoths and
now this 25.2 meter long
blue whale skeleton named hope suspended
elegantly from the ancient ceiling
behind me
but perhaps this museum's greatest magic
trick
is that it has fired the imagination of
young people
to care for our planet and all its
species
all this time the museum has perhaps
been teaching us the most important
lesson of all
that we are all part of the same natural
ecosystem i feel truly honored to be
hosting this ceremony because
we're here to pay tribute to the world's
teachers
the most important people when it comes
to shaping our very future
and despite the world being turned
upside down
the vacuum foundation has been
determined
this year more than ever to shine a
light on
the teaching profession but today's
ceremony will be different to how we
usually do things because of the
strange difficult and heartbreaking
times we find ourselves in
this will be our first virtual prize
ceremony
but what really matters is that we still
take the time
to pause reflect and think
about the world's teachers and most of
all we are holding this ceremony
because we want to say thank you thank
you to
all the teachers in the world thank you
for your creativity
thank you for your compassion and thank
you for never giving up
never has the world been in more need of
hard-won
knowledge rather than instant opinions
rather than knee-jerk reactions and
sound judgment
rather than sensationalism in a world of
strong
loud opinions the one voice that should
never be drowned out
is that of the teacher this year as well
as announcing the winner of the global
teacher prize
2020 we will also pay tribute to a
special teacher who has made a profound
difference
in helping young people keep learning
during this
year of kovid a year in which the
educational landscape has been
utterly transformed but before that
let us take a look back at this heroic
year of teaching
one in which the world's teachers have
gone above
and beyond kovid 19
can be characterized as a pandemic
the madhya pradesh government on friday
ordered closure of schools
after schools shut their gates from
friday
afternoon they will remain closed
until further notice several thousand
teachers and students
have become infected with the virus now
schools in the country are still
closed as part of a lockdown to contain
the coronavirus but many have reopened
virtually you know even if they are not
the students are not in school
learning should still take place and
there's you know it's not limited to
the four world classroom there's no holy
grail
and a teacher has to be some kind of a
pedagogical engineer
teacher leadership is right now the most
important thing in education
bar none right now we're in a crisis you
have to teach
two-year context
[Music]
even before cover 19 we must remember
that millions of young people were
already living without a birthright
of a good teacher and a quality
education
in 2020 we faced a brand new global
threat
covet 19 which has exacerbated the
situation
even further in mid-july schools were
closed
in more than 160 countries affecting
over 1 billion students at least 40
million children worldwide have missed
out on education in the critical
preschool
years but in this
hour of darkness the world has
discovered
new research of creativity of compassion
or resolve a school sorry opening for
learning
hospitals are being built in days rather
than years
and governments have reversed any
direction overnight
we see acts of giving acts of kindness
everywhere and we will all
pay the price of these challenges which
means that we all have to come together
and invest in humanity invest in
education
[Music]
so thank you yasmin sharif director of
education cannot wait for taking us
beyond the news headlines and
reminding us of how millions of children
continue to be affected by conflicts
natural disasters and displacement
due to the remarkable times we find
ourselves in this year
as well as announcing the winner of the
global teacher prize 2020
we would like to present another award
the varkey foundation wants to recognize
one
very special teacher who has made an
extraordinary difference
in helping young people keep learning
during this pandemic
to introduce the global teacher prize
coved
hero award supported by cvc capital
partners
i would like to welcome stefania
giannini
assistant director general of education
at unesco
thank you stephen i'm honored to speak
to you today at the global teacher prize
ceremony unesco is a proud partner of
the global teacher prize
and a word that has done so much to
highlight
how teachers transform the lives of
young people everywhere since the
coronavirus pandemic first emerged
we have seen 1.5 billion learners across
the world
impacted by school and university
closures
but sadly not all learners are being
impacted equally
despite the best force of introduced
remote learning
unfortunately over 700 million of the
world
1.7 billion learners lack internet
access and this is why unesco set up the
global education coalition to engage
telecommunication and technology
partners to take action
to bridge the digital divide i want to
thank everyone
that has stepped forward to join this
coalition
but we need to do so much more
governments must
learn the lessons from this pandemic
and dock decisively to ensure all
children receive a quality education
in this age of khabib and beyond
most importantly it's vital that we put
the teacher voice at the heart of our
mission
the combined knowledge and experience of
teachers from the front line will help
the international community answer
crucial questions
so we can provide inclusive learning
opportunities for all children in the
world
and this is why the vaki foundation has
established this year
the carved hero award to bring attention
to the steadfast determination of the
worst teachers to keep the next
generation learning
i am now honored to introduce academy
award winning actor
and unesco special invoice for peace and
reconciliation
for the sweetaker to announce the winner
of the global teacher prize calvi the
hero howard
thank you i'm delighted to speak at such
a wonderful celebration
of the teaching profession as unesco
special envoy for peace and
reconciliation
i believe that education is on the front
line of making peace happen
between and within communities in this
respect
teachers always bring more than
knowledge and skills they open the minds
and hearts of our children
they create an awareness that the future
can always be a better place
than they do this every day most of this
work goes unnoticed because
teachers puts their students in the
spotlight
for me the global teacher prize is an
inspirational idea because it turns that
spotlight
and shines it on the unsung heroes who
teach in the classrooms
all around the world teachers like our
top 10 finalists here tonight
this year during the pandemic we have
seen the biggest disruption
to education in history and yet we have
seen teachers go above and beyond to
keep the world's children
learning today we will honor one very
special teacher
i'm delighted to announce that the
global teacher prize covet hero award
goes to
jamie frost from the united kingdom
jamie
your internationally acclaimed website
for math tuition dr frost mass
has had over 7 million resource
downloads and is making
fun for children all over the world
especially during the pandemic
your creativity and dedication have
illuminated millions of minds for free
thank you jamie thank you to all the
world's teachers
thank you very much forest for all the
passion dedication you put into your
role as unesco's special envoy for peace
and reconciliation
and a huge congratulation jamie and now
i would like to welcome the prime
minister of the united kingdom
the right honorable boris johnson who
could like to give
a special message of congratulations
thank you
good afternoon it is a real pleasure to
speak to you today
at the global teacher prize ceremony
broadcast from london
in the united kingdom as the global
teacher prize ceremony now
moves around the world making its
reputation
live up to its name as a true global
celebration of teachers
it's an honor that london has been
chosen as the first of the new host
cities
although i'm speaking to you in
difficult and sometimes heartbreaking
circumstances it's right that we take
time to recognize
the enormous contribution and sacrifice
of the world's teachers during this
pandemic
teachers like you jamie frost
congratulations on winning the global
teacher prize
coved hero award
your creativity and ingenuity has given
hope
and support to millions of children
throughout the world
it's been incredible to see how teachers
have adapted
to home learning and use technology to
continue with lessons
throughout the pandemic
you don't just represent the heroic
teachers in the united kingdom
but also across the whole world
thank you once again to all the world's
teachers
congratulations jamie on winning the
global teacher prize
coved hero award i look forward to
speaking to you
shortly but i'm now very excited to talk
to all the top 10
finalists of the global teacher prize
2020.
from 140 countries we received over 12
000 nominations and applications and now
we have
10 finalists they've been selected based
on
how they improve student outcomes how
they innovate
introduce scalable practices share their
knowledge
make an impact in the community and
develop global citizens but what has
become
very clear is that all ten teachers
share one very special thing in common
they may be spread all over the world
from
europe to latin america to africa
working in cities
villages and even in rainforests but
they all
share the same one precious quality
something we are more in need of today
than
anything else probably these teachers
are all selfless
always thinking about their students
and their futures our ten finalists
have taught their students from every
country culture and faith
that there is more that unites than
divides them
more that bonds than breaks them
more that draws them together than pulls
them apart
these teachers have opened their
students minds to see
that people everywhere share the same
values hopes
dreams and disappointments but most
importantly
the stories of these ten teachers
clearly remind us all
that there is no end to poverty without
education there is no end to disease
without education there is no solution
to climate change
without education and as the blue whale
above reminds us
there is no hope without education
perhaps sonny varkey the founder of the
global teacher prize
put it best when he said whatever the
question
education is the answer
so let's sit back and watch our
top 10 finalists heroic
i journeys learning a language is not
simply learning a language
but it is learning a new culture a new
world
english is a tool to remove
their world barriers and to have a
better life
but right classroom model enabled me to
connect my ethnic minority students
with global teachers and students
education is the best
channel to change the world
right
our journey to america project has our
students writing stories about how they
came to the united states
refugees immigrants they make up about
30 to 40 percent of our school
population
i am able to help students feel like
they all
have a voice and people are interested
in what they have to say
i have lives of people bestowed in my
hands
i carried it every day in my heart
critical thinking creative thinking
collaboration they are proud to have
their indigenous knowledge implemented
in the classroom
this is the digital age and if learners
are
not competent with their peers globally
they will find themselves left behind
ten years ago i was developing
technology for artificial intelligence
and the photos
but now i use technology to help
students improve in their learning and
i'm the creator
of drfrostmaths.com i love being able to
use my knowledge of programming to
develop new technologies and yeah i just
love working with students
[Music]
from
when your focus is in transformation of
life
you are helping a child to fulfill his
destiny
you are a mentor then you can say
you are a true teacher that has values
[Music]
i will teach in such a way that i can
link whatever they are learning with the
popular downstairs
with music around there when they cannot
even learn
the way you teach why not teach them the
way they learn
i just wanted to create a learning
environment for every student
that could spark the curiosity i have
made some qr codes under each and every
textbook
so when the students can do qr score
he or she gets the personalized and well
curated content for himself
girls education is more about feeling
safe in the community in the society
teachers are actually catalysts that can
really
make the world a much better place
one of the most important values in
teaching
is knowing and believing that every
child
has the capability to learn i wanted my
aurangasi children to have similar
learning experiences in comparison to an
elite school
i somehow knew that if i could make
learning
something they could relate to
something that is meaningful to their
culture and also their lives
i might have a chance
definitely
truly inspiring now
it is my great pleasure to introduce you
to the
heroes of this occasion the top 10
finalists
of the global teacher prize 2020. here
they are
joining us from every corner of the
planet from italy
brazil vietnam the united kingdom the
usa
south africa nigeria india malaysia
and south korea a very warm welcome
to all our top 10 finalists let's
welcome our first of the top ten
finalists who is
carlo matsoni from benevento in italy
good morning and benevolent from
benevento in italy carlo
how are you doing oh okay i'm very
anxious and very proud
very honored of this and i want to
uh thank you for your kind words
when you told me that i was in the top
10.
thank you and it's great to see the
italian flag in the background there
and uh congratulations to you and all
your family
and now let's let's welcome now duwani
e manuela berton from brazil
a very good morning to you as well and i
can see you signing what i'm saying or
signing something thank you auriga
now who should we turn to well i'd like
you all to give a very warm welcome
to ha and all the way from vietnam
i believe as i'm speaking it's evening
in vietnam
so good evening and how are you feeling
full
yeah we are so excited here this is my
big family
and today is maybe order to have the big
family and the house mothers
uh from hong kong high school to be here
we are so excited nice to see you guys
so
oh it's wonderful to see you and i'd
like to welcome
jamie frost from the united kingdom not
so far away from here perhaps
but uh jamie you've just won
the covid hero award for your
internationally acclaimed
free website that is making maths
accessible for children
all over the world so already a winner
how do you feel
i feel absolutely fantastic to see it
and by the way i'm a massive fan i've
watched you on tv
since i was young um it just it's it's
such a knowledge just to receive this
award and i'm just
so happy that so many students have been
able to benefit from my site so and
that's what i want really thank you
jamie i'd now like to give a very warm
welcome
to leah julke from north dakota in the
usa
it's very early morning there i think
leah how you doing
yes it is very early morning um thank
you so much i'm so excited to be here
this is my daughter samara and we are
just
thrilled to be here even though it's
really early uh
we are up for it well we're delighted to
have you
and now i'd like to give a very warm
welcome to
mukudu machaba all the way from limpopo
in south africa mukudo how are you doing
thank you steve and i'm doing very fine
and how are you
i'm very well indeed good to see the
balloons and the flag in the background
and you've got some friends and family
supporting you i see
and i'd now like to welcome all our sun
gourmet
or paiifa from nigeria welcome to this
very special ceremony and
congratulations
how are you doing today
well it's wonderful to have you and now
i'd like to give a very warm welcome
to ranjit de saleh from maharashtra
in india good evening ranjit good
evening
very well indeed very good to see you
namaste and now i'd like to say a very
good evening
to samuel isaiah from malaysia welcome
and congratulations samuel how are you i
see you in front of the flag
yes uh we are grateful to be here and
humbled as well
thank you for your kind wishes stephen
it's a real pleasure
and finally i'd like to welcome young
jiong hyun
from south korea to our global teacher
prize ceremony
how are you doing
so now we've met our remarkable top 10
finalists it can mean
only one thing that we're almost ready
for the moment
you've all been waiting for but before
we announce the winner of the global
teacher prize
2020 we would like to set the scene
by presenting a very special musical
performance
70 children from 10 countries working
under the guidance of their music
teachers
have come together to form a very
special global teacher prize
virtual choir we would like to thank
music director mr patrick vaccariello
and former global teacher prize finalist
mr ron davis
alvarez for overseeing the performance
and because teachers everywhere have
shown such courage
against all the odds these young
musicians have chosen to sing
the beautiful and inspiring song brave
written by sarah bareille this is
dedicated
to all the teachers in the world
enjoy
you can turn a be into a weapon or a
drug
you can give me the outcast to be the
backlash
[Music]
i wonder what would happen if you say
what you want to say and let the words
fall
out honestly
[Music]
i just wanna see you
i just wanna see you i just wanna see
you
i just wanna see you
everybody's been there everybody's been
stared down by
the enemy falling for the fear and done
some disappearing
don't run stop holding your tongue
baby there's a way out of the cage
[Music]
honestly
do you think you would
[Music]
honestly
is
[Music]
i just wanna see
i wanna
[Music]
i just want to see
so thank you to the young musicians and
teachers from all over the world for
that wonderful tribute
to the world's teachers and now
we reach the climax of this year's
global teacher prize ceremony
the moment where we announced the winner
of the global teacher prize
2020 where we honor an exceptional
teacher that has made an outstanding
contribution
to the profession someone who will use
this platform
to give voice to teachers all over the
world and of course
with the title comes a one million
dollar
prize fund and the winner
the global teacher prize 2020
is ranjit desali from india
[Music]
oh look there's your whole extended
family now
it's wonderful oh my dear fellow you i
can see how moved you are
um if i can ask you just just to get
yourself together
enough ranjit can i invite you to say
a few words about about receiving this
this award
hello everyone namaste and
thank you thank you so much foundation
the founder of global teacher prize and
its partner
unesco for celebrating teachers in a
great manner
and this is such a great honor and i'm
receiving
this honor on behalf of millions of
millions of students
teachers those who are working hard in
this
in these hard times of kobe
and those who are working to lighten the
life of millions of students
and making sure that the birthright
of getting quality education
teachers are real change makers
and they do change the lives of students
with a mixture of job and challenges
the beliefs in sharing
because sharing is growing and therefore
today i would like to announce
that the 50
of the prize money will be equally
shared with the rest of nine
top 10 finalists
because i believe together
we can make a difference and we can make
this world a better place
once again i'd like to thank you all
lucky foundation and all the team
members
thank you stephen and unesco for
celebrating teachers
in this in this incredible way i
i'm just humbled that's wonderful
well congratulations again and how lucky
i think we all know
your students are to have you as a
teacher i'll let you go now because i
know that all generations of your family
are very proud and want to help you
celebrate and enjoy this
very special moment well
thank you that concludes this very
special global teacher prize ceremony
that rightly pays tribute to a
profession that is the mother
of all professions and i'd like to thank
everyone around the world
that has taken the time to tune in and
celebrate with me
we'd like to leave you now with just
some of the messages that are coming in
from around the world congratulating
ranjit for his extraordinary
achievements
i'm sure there'll be many more tributes
in the days
and weeks ahead so it just leaves me to
say
thank you ranjit and every single
teacher
in the world only by backing teachers
can we build a better future so thank
you
now please stay safe take care of each
other
goodbye congratulations to ranjit
de saleh for winning the global teacher
prize
2020 which partners with unesco
[Music]
you represent the creativity compassion
and resolve of all teachers especially
during this pandemic
i now encourage you to use this platform
to give every teacher a voice
it's my great pleasure to congratulate
mr ranjitsin
di saleh from maharashtra in india for
winning this year's global teacher
prize unesco is a proud partner of the
global teacher prize
an award that has done so much to
highlight
how teachers transform the lives of
young people everywhere
ranjitsin's story is testimony
that the best teachers combine their
knowledge
strength and great spirit to help
those most urgent in need
that's why today i'm urging the
international community
to act now to save our future to protect
education budgets
to invest in teachers teachers need our
support
now more than ever by backing incredible
teachers like ranjit we can find a way
through
and defeat this crisis ranjitin's story
shows us the real difference that one
teacher can make
and i know and you know that there are
thousands more teachers just like
ranjitsings
around the world
[Music]
has worked tirelessly for all of his
students
and in his particular he has improved
the quality
of education for girls ranjit sin
is an inspiration to all of us his
teaching
has transformed the lives of his
students
[Music]
is a dynamic teacher whose work has
transformed the lives of his students in
india
and his story has inspired the many
around the world
today we honor his determination
kindness
and service to the next generation the
united nations
and unesco's task is to build a 21st
century
that is more peaceful more inclusive
more just and more sustainable
and this cannot happen without
teachers teachers like ranjit sin
are the key to unlocking the future we
want granite since
story shows all of us how a good teacher
can transform the lives of the students
no matter how hard the context or how
few the resources
available to them
[Music]
you